hey guys so today we're on our way to
sitting in the street to a little nook
called pop art and so what pop art is it
is what it is a ice cream shop
I like Pinkberry but not Pinkberry now
yogurt man but ice cream on a stick hot
bar and our close friends David Barton
Joe have teamed up and opened up a store
yes it's really exciting cuz you know a
really close good friend brothers family
they opened up this pop bar so we
organized a meeting greet for all of our
la people because I know some of you
guys out there that are from LA and you
guys find out that we have meeting rates
into other places you guys are always
like what about us you know if the
people that you know in your very own
hometown you guys never show us love so
now we are you we're going to be having
the street agreed for you guys and I'm
curious to see how many of you guys
actually showed up and we're going to
eat some ice cream even though it's a
rainy day
you guys don't notice in LA whenever it
rains everyone freaks out these we're
not used to the rain it cooks like
really get rain like how often once a
year yeah it's like very very one week
out of here it rains we freak out for a
very real reason though right because
the center doesn't rain that often
there's nothing to wash away that
buildup of three sets on the floor so
when it fine does rain it's extra it
literally there's like mad grease and
like just gunk on the streets that never
never gets washed away by rain I'm
actually surprised that we are not stuck
in traffic right now because every time
it rains in LA
everyone's going like 10 miles an hour
because it is really scary against kind
of slippery that's funny I had a friend
that you worked at cold stone the ice
cream place and he told me that during
the winter time like when it was colder
that that's when they would sell the
most ice cream why do you think that
easy do you think people are trying to
psyche themselves out trying to like
trick themselves into thinking it's
still summer isn't it they want to eat
something cold
maybe there's a theory out there that
says if it's cold outside you see cold
stuff and if it's hot outside sheet hot
stuff physically the temperatures can
cancel each other out kind of like you
ever walk into a it's hot outside and
walk into an air-conditioned mall yeah
oh my gosh it feels so great and when
you walk back outside though it's like
way oh my gosh oh yeah you're right
that's true yeah but if you just stay
outside and just kind of deal with it
for a little bit eventually you're like
keep your body adjust to the temperature
there's a long one
oh my goodness look at all the people oh
that's so cool
yeah they're all here to see it that's
pretty insane that's a lot of people now
we gotta find parking is it pop bar is a
JK I know are they here for the
obstacles pretty here for us yet in Joe
with this so apparently Michael's got
like a secret door for us
you're excited
I can't believe this is happening the
line is all the way down there but
there's a lot more people that expect
this I'm so thankful that there's so
many people down to come here waiting
for hours here waiting since 6:00 a.m.
it's pretty crazy
so I guess like a pickle your possible
sequence
I recommend we take the popsicles and we
just chuck it
one step one step one
Oh
Hey
flavor you guys got I love coffee oh
yeah pistachio pistachio okay I get a
can I get your favorite combination on
it yeah thank you
good eat it eat it eat it
I mean me
oh I gotta go gotta go gotta go huh we
made it made it out when we're leaving
we're actually running away because then
we hear this he's like other group of
fans like around the corner they're like
why are you guys running we're like
sorry guys we gotta go those re like I
feel so bad to like I know what it feels
like to be a fan of someone and to want
to just be with them and like tell them
how much you love them because they're
inspiring to you and you watch this
person you follow them and you feel like
you know them and you feel like you guys
are close friends and you're connected
but yeah we still I mean we feel it it's
all up we're about to eat now I gotta do
some b-roll dude biro biro biro - Wow
being a part of it
what happened